bonjour bonjour monsieur
excusez moi cette corde avait bien pour
pour faire de nous allez assez épaisses
et pour faire quel genre de ne pas
lasser point noeud coulant aucun
problème et pourrait soutenir d'un poids
de 70 kg et de voir le modèle
si par exemple la charge c'était un
homme un seul ça pouvait aller jusqu'à
500 kg de levage là n'ont qu'à y a pas
de souci par contre faut vraiment faire
attention à fixer sur quelque chose de
résistants l'autre pour fixer dans un
appart à queue une poutre apparente
et puis pas trop de meubles pascal à
tout prix ok bah c'est parfait ça
devrait tenir
vous auriez des tabourets qu'on pourrait
facilement renversé avec les pieds oui
bien sûr les tabourets c'est au fond
tout droit si on ajoute le poids de la
culpabilité d'avoir déçu sa famille et
perdu tous ses proches tiendra toujours
voilà je sais pas monsieur va falloir
essayer
bonne journée bien non monsieur
attendait oui le rayon tabouret sa
gauche
et on reprend nos clients que des cartes
de fidélité sont disponibles en cliquant
sur votre toit
profitez-en tout doit disparaître